[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting which is a little bit different
we'll talk about that in a second oh
yeah uh i'm gonna be talking about uh my
recent trip to san francisco the san
francisco treat yeah did you get some
treats uh i did get some treats
uh i you know it was it was quite an
experience made some memories what was
the mission uh the mission was
college visits for locke trying to
decide on where he's gonna go so there's
a few schools in the san francisco area
uh that we visited so you're yeah you're
entering that
phase of fatherhood that that i went
through last year and then
next year
with lincoln
i'll be going through it again the
second time it won't be breezed though
i hope so i mean it's like i wonder what
you've learned from me and i wonder what
i can learn from you for next time it's
funny i wasn't thinking about what i
wasn't i wasn't a well the funny thing
is is that if i recall
correctly lily kind of she kind of had
her mind set on what she wanted to do
where she wanted to go and there wasn't
like like lock has applied to like 25
different schools
you know we've visited multiple schools
we're going for a spring break now the
spring break trip is shaping up and it's
turning into a tour of the northeastern
united states oh wow
including new york where the you know
the be so
some some schools up there that he's
interested that's why i think maybe i
can learn from you because i did you
know
i was not nearly that involved yeah it
was like a handful of schools that she
applied to
and
um
in the in the timing of the pandemic of
it all yeah there was
there was
it was much more limited what what we
were capable of doing and what colleges
were capable of uh giving us as far as
like the funny thing is is we don't you
know we don't mclaughlins are not great
planners and so there we have not taken
any official tours we haven't talked to
anyone official like literally one of
the campuses we were walking around and
there was like a group of official kids
with like an official representative
we're just like hey guys losers we can
go wherever
that's going to be pertinent to your
decision we don't need an official
person we're going to the snack shop
yeah right i mean we make our own rules
man
i feel like i'm not going to spend i'll
spend some time talking about that but i
also want to talk about san francisco
um
turns out there's a lot to talk about as
it relates to san francisco and i saw a
picture that you texted
christy and i
and i'm very intrigued i want to talk
about the specifics of this picture that
you sent us to so yeah i'm excited about
that but yeah we're also excited about
the fact that the ear biscuits set has
been updated our backdrop
this reflects
an expanding universe of mythical
podcasts that
is our
that's our vision and we got plans to
back it up baby matter of fact the first
new podcast coming out of mythical
studios
is
trevor talks too much tomorrow
episode one comes out um you you know
trevor he's one of the mythical
kitcheners
uh
well there's a few things about trump
he's the goofy young guy who talks yeah
trevor i don't know if he is still the
youngest person to work in mythical
entertainment but you know what i mean
he's a he's a z or a gen zer
and so um he's interested in things and
talks about things that we're too old to
understand or appreciate
uh and so don't stop talking to us just
start talking to other people you're
interested in talking to so he's gonna
have guests he's gonna have guests that
are kind of uh in in in his world
uh
one of the guests we're not going to
mention because we don't know you never
know who you're going to get in here i
do know one of the guests i mean i have
heard of one of the guests and actually
i've had conversations with one of the
guests
but the other ones i'm like i just the
fact that i don't know who they are is a
good sign
that trevor's doing the right thing but
if if what we're saying intrigues you
check out his podcast what we're saying
doesn't intrigue you i don't listen to
us just check out his podcast don't let
us be the reason you don't check out his
podcast trevor's a lovely man
trevor talks too much
almost down it was almost the name of
the podcast
that was my vote trevor's a lovely man
also there's a youtube channel dedicated
to the visual version where you can
check out this backdrop with his own
signage
up here but apparently he doesn't get
our round table or i think they they
have something over it but apparently
this wood which i love wood and i love
touching it uh is a wave form
we've been told it may or may not say
mythical is love
it also could just be someone farting
yeah
but it looks like it could be warmed up
it's very beautiful i like to fart love
could you pretty cool huh
i think farts if you're just listening
to this pretty cool huh this would be a
pretty this would be a fart that started
strong and had a whimper in the middle
then came back
yeah ain't really picked up again which
are my favorite kinds
right you've made people think they're
over and you bring it right back it's
called breaking the second wind yeah
okay uh let's talk about this trip now
you've made this you've made the trip to
the northern part of our state i want to
talk a little bit about that area that
you haven't dropped north of san
francisco
but that's pretty neither have i really
okay
a lot more
a whole lot so yeah we i still want to
go up that way i'm talking about
this is the experience okay just in case
you've never taken this route and i'm
talking about being on the five the
interstate five
going north you take it out of town you
go past the sort of the remnants of
civilization on the north side of los
angeles like up to santa clarita and you
kind of enter into this mountain pass
and all of a sudden
it's like okay there's no people here
anymore i mean there's mountains it's a
wilderness area kind of
it's actually where we drove when we
went we took shepherd up and did some
off-roading there's like a little
envelope
place there
but you drive through this and then you
kind of come down out of the mountains
and it's very very sudden
mountains and then all of a sudden
flatness yeah for as far as you can see
and it is
for like four and a half hours straight
you are on what feels like having just
recently driven across north texas feels
like north texas like flat and just
crops
yeah like this is where
the stuff that's grown in california is
grown it's the central valley right 18
wheelers
on the road and it is so
desolate yeah it's it's um it's it's a
tough drive yeah because it just never
changes yeah but did you have you
noticed this
uh
the people who grow the food in this
area
have very they seem to have a very
particular uh political viewpoint on our
governor have you noticed this
well yeah they tried to recall him no no
no i'm saying i'm not talking about just
northern california i'm talking about
specifically the people who own the
farms there's all these signs
calling out governor newsom about water
yeah you notice this and it's just like
and there's a play on words it's like
give us back our damn water but they
spelled damn with the dam
oh and then there's the sign like you
you the signs sort of educate you as you
go along there's there's other ones that
say 70 of our water flows into the
oceans without so you know obviously
there's some there's two different
there's a difference of opinion here
yeah there's probably
like a progressive environmental side
that's saying that we can't just dam up
and use all this water for whatever
habitats etc i don't know any of the
details i'm just kind of pulling this
out of my butt right now and then the
second thing is well we want to grow the
crops let us just use the water let us
dam this stuff up so we can use it
whatever and so these two
you know ideals are sort of bumping up
against each other and for like four
hours and it's just sign after sign
after sign after sign
there's no because there's really like
hardly any billboards it's just these
you saw all these signs and you never
figured it out i think the signs have
worked their way into my mind and i'm
like governor newsom give us back our
damn water like i mean this propaganda
has worked for me i don't know the
details so i'm actually i don't know
where i come down on this issue because
i don't have any idea what is at stake i
should probably look into it but that
was your understanding
but then did you notice
that the desolation turns into
rolling hills
with no trees
and it looks i mean it looks grassy
there'll be some uh it's beautiful
grassy some yellow flowers we we we've
benefited from a lot of rain which is
very unusual it's very brown but once
you what i'm talking about you're almost
in the bay area okay you guys like to go
to the santa cruz area so at some point
you kind of go off of the five
right but we were going all the way up
to san francisco and we were in the way
that it was navigating us was coming all
the way up through oakland almost to
berkeley and then cutting across the bay
into san francisco right
so
for like another two hours i mean the
whole trip is like five and a half hours
so like it's like three and a half hour
four hours and then like the last hour
and a half is these rolling hills
with nothing nothing on them except
cattle yeah and windmills
it's pretty cool
it's beautiful
but this is where this dynamic begins
where i begin pointing out things i'm
totally doubting it when i'm driving
everybody's on their phones i'm not on a
phone i'm on a car
yeah you have to see everything and i'm
like guys look at those cows in fact we
literally had this conversation jesse
and i did and she ended up tweeting
about it because she thought it was so
funny
i said
look at those cows just living up there
on those hills and she said
i've already looked at the cows and i
was just like but look at them now
[Laughter]
you know now that i've just given you a
philosophical point of view on them
but right yeah let's be thoughtful about
these cows and i don't really want to go
into listen some people say that the
tendency to want people to look at
things is narcissism okay whatever
i think it is i what i want is i want a
connection man it's just like when
you're with somebody you're watching a
movie well you want somebody to you want
to bring somebody into a collective
experience i'm just looking for a
connection with my family i get it man
you're you're that's all dad's want
you're a dad who wants when you're all
together
you want the you want to have a shared
focal point and if that's a cow so be it
and it's the dad's job the dad's role in
the family is to find the focal point
and to
exclaim it yeah just grab everybody's
face and say look at that cow
look at a car living in his life he sits
up there living his life just think
about those cows though man they just
make their they make their lives on
these hills hey i'm not on your trip
don't drag me into this but one of the
things that started happening as we got
closer is i started realizing that i was
literally seeing
the screen saver not screen saver but
the background for what is it windows
vista yeah the two beautiful green hills
with the little uh yellow flowers on and
the beautiful blue sky behind them oh
the reason that you see that is because
you're getting into silicon valley man
silicon you're up there where all this
stuff is actually originated and made
and so i was like i bet you i'm looking
at these two hills i bet you these hills
are i think i passed the microsoft hills
man i think it's an early dell
commercial too
dell's probably up there too that's why
the dell is cows cows
your focal point
we've just unlocked the mysteries of
dell
is dell still around
hell yeah i mean they sponsored an
episode like last
dell small business man dell's still
around they sponsored two episodes of
ear biscuits this podcast within the
last 12 months i remember that now
you're still around
i meant now
is it in our contract for linkedin know
that they're still around because we
might need to need to amend it it's been
a year it's been a year a lot can happen
but that's how the cows come from all
right
and then you're just
okay see these are the things i see the
cat i've seen these are the things that
dads are thinking about
you know just let them have their
moments
okay
and and when you're experiencing
something that you don't see all the
time and you see the rest of your family
is
uninterested or in their phone or asleep
you're like you had a hey this is a
moment what i end up saying things like
guys
whatever is on your phone right now
whether it's a game or
snapchat or twitter
it will still be there in five minutes
but you know what won't be here those
cows i mean they'll be new cows they'll
be new cats there'll be more cows
different cows that look exactly the
same as the cows that you can see right
now but just look at those cows but you
but you kind of uh
you know
excuse my french you blew your wad on
on the cows when you should have saved
it for like
seeing the skyline of san francisco for
the first time i was trying to train the
family to be if they if i could get him
to look at cows i could get him to look
at the golden gate bridge and i think i
think blowing your wad is a it's an it's
a firearm
thing it's like a gunpowder firearm
thing so i don't think it's french yeah
yeah yeah right i agree with that yeah
it's think it's been co-opted
by the sexually minded but
that is not what i was thinking of
um i'll tell you some more things i was
thinking of in a moment uh but we do
want to remind you even though link
already said it we do want to remind you
that
trevor's podcast trevor talks too much
has a youtube channel just like your
biscuits does subscribe to it go ahead
you know what
go ahead go over there
even if you're not gonna listen and
watch just subscribe give it a shot for
support support trevor trying new things
show them your support it's not easy to
start new things
just ask a cow
hmm that analogy didn't work yeah
i can't i just i can't support you on
that front but i do start up
startups like in silicon valley okay
there we go
trevor's podcast is a startup trevor
talks too much
super proud to be launching some
another podcast more to follow
that's right we're cooking up some more
podcasts
for you
i want to talk about the
process of
a college tour and again made clear that
this is not an official college tour
this is just a family walking around a
college campus you're just showing up
pulling on doors seeing what's open
um
parking in places that you may not
should park hoping you don't get towed
trying to interpret parking signs that's
a
that's a gift of mine oh it is yeah
living in los angeles i've had to learn
how to take it's a good training ground
different rules that are unrelated
and figure out if the moment right now
i'm able to park here
yeah san francisco has the same i really
wish it were diagrams you know like a
venn diagram of i just would the whole
then i could go up to and i could put my
finger on where i'm at and then i could
look and see if i could park there or
not well in the future maybe use a laser
pointer the whole curve will be green or
red
can it park here now or can i not yeah
led that thing yeah leds are cheap man
yeah led the whole if i was mayor of los
angeles we would led all curbs
get rid of the signs that's a fun idea
yeah i mean just vote for me i'll figure
it out
what's your what's your stance on the
water
situation you know what i'm taking that
and
under advisement
okay and uh i believe both in crops and
in ecological environments and i believe
that there is a way that we can both win
we can we can all win california can win
running for governor
did you go
d i mean
when we were looking at the few campuses
that we looked at
i mean you really couldn't go in
anything at the time so we were like
looking peering through windows nobody
was there yeah so we're walking around
yeah you can get a little bit more you
can go in to a few places like every the
student centers are open and like
bookstore actually the bookstore one
place was closed because we are still in
a little bit of a
uh
at the time that we were doing this we
were in a little bit of a surge so
um but the thing that i i do
i'm trying to be helpful right like it's
what you're trying to do as a parent
usually always if you're being healthy
you're trying to actually be helpful
and so
which the only way to do that
usually is you you picture yourself at
that age and what would i want somebody
to tell me and i try not to i really try
not to do that
um because i found that not to be
effective but also with locke in
particular like the moment that he
senses a dadism or sort of a lecture or
a perspective coming from on high
um so he bristles at it was the cow
thing a wake-up call for you that you're
then applied to being on campus
don't answer that just tell me your
story and that's gonna be my question
well i can go and answer that question
for you because the cow thing was more
me and jesse like the kids are so in
their own worlds in the back they didn't
even hear me and this is that it was
just me talking to my wife
um
but
you know and uh and the thing is is i
see the way that lock is so similar to
me in the way that he
places himself in an environment
and he
you know he immediately
fast forwards through the next four
years and it's like this is what it
would be like and this is where i would
live and this is where i would live
after and this is the kind of job that i
would have
he can very quickly picture
his future at this particular place and
that's kind of how and i'm the same way
i do it kind of just it's my nature and
that's how you figure out if you are
into it i do the same thing if i read a
book i do the same thing as i'm driving
across the freaking state it's like i'm
reading these signs i'm like yeah give
us our damn water newsome you know what
i'm saying like that's what i do i
i embody the perspective and see what it
feels like
and then i pull back from it once i've
kind of investigated it i'm very open in
that way right and and and to like the
possibilities of the future and so so
you would expect him to be
excited at each place he went to and if
there wasn't an initial excitement and
that's a huge red flag for somebody who
can embody
a life there well uh like in a
fantastical kind of way but this is the
thing because he so he does that so
naturally i don't there's with lock in
particular there's none i don't have to
do
what i think is probably more typical
it's just like hey man
think some things about this you know
yeah with lock it's like hey dude let's
like let's pull back a little bit
and
you know
because the way it the way i feel about
it is is that whatever mood he's in when
he's visiting a certain place and the
timing works out it's just like the old
principle of you get married based on
when you meet somebody in life
circumstances
they're super practical
like it's completely unromantic there's
no such thing as soul mates which i'm
not saying i subscribe to but some
people would say marriage is a is just
is who you are in love with at the time
when you could get married right
i don't necessarily believe that but
there is an element of circumstance with
who and hopefully you get lucky and here
with the right person i feel that way
about my marriage but when it comes to
college it's just like you think about
how circumstantial and again we just
chose between carolina and state right
that was the two only two schools we
applied to got accepted in both
and then like
i remember taking a tour of unc
and again if you remember this i was
probably talking to you like this is we
would do this and this is how i'm i'm
living out the next four years and being
like this is what it's going to be like
and then going to state and doing the
same thing
in the end it was i do have a hard time
remembering the specifics of it
but
knowing how difficult it's just the two
of us we drove ourselves up there i
remember that specifically no parents we
just drove up there together and walked
around
and it's a really impressive campus so
it was very enticing
but the entire time like we were never
carolina fans i was always a state fan
and you were
a duke i was a duke fan because we were
from out of town it was like we felt we
don't want anybody to see us like it's
not that anybody would
yeah you may have felt that way i didn't
have any wrong feelings about that
and my brother was already there you
know my brother was at school there
um we ended up going to state just
because it was like oh yeah i'm taking
physics and and i like mr bryant who's
teaching it you know what i'm saying it
was such a
oh yeah but because i know that that's
how kids make decisions it's in in in
lot can get so passionate about
something i'm trying to
sort of modulate mitigate whatever the
word is
and then the opportunity
to
go to a basketball game presented itself
oh okay in this particular school that
we were looking at lot gets on his phone
the night before and he's like dad
they're playing gonzaga
gonzaga pretty good number two team in
the nation with the number one player in
the nation it's like a six that's like a
seven foot point guard i don't even
remember the dude's name but he's like a
seven foot point guard
that's like
very it would be amazing to watch you
know just imagine it'd be a good game
and it might seal the deal for like oh i
had such a great experience i have to
well that's what i was thinking and i
was also thinking like you because this
is not it's a relatively small school
with like a gym that's like the size of
like campbell's gym and going and seeing
like gonzaga play in a place like that
so we get on we do go on seat geek not a
sponsor
and we we find three we find three
tickets not four and jesse's like it's
fine i don't really care i'll just like
well i'll go to a coffee shop hang out
while you guys go to the game so we're
like okay
three tickets
last minute
gonzaga
150 bucks a pop okay so it's like this
is a but i'm like this hey listen let's
do this because this is what what else
are you going to be doing it's a cool
experience but i was also thinking man
even though they're definitely going to
get beat by gonzaga
this is going if he sees like other
students like there and he has this
experience this might seal the deal for
him so but that's not necessarily a good
thing i'm worried about it but i'm also
like i kind of want to see this game
okay
so we get the tickets
and then game day
which was the next day we go up to the
gym you know like half an hour early and
the guy like sees i pull out the tickets
he's like um
so we're operating at 25 capacity today
due to covid
so we're going to scan your tickets if
they scan green you can come in if they
scan red oh wow you can't
and he and he said and the way we're
doing that is is that all season ticket
holders are allowed to come in but
anyone who bought
single game tickets
and then resold them
they've already been refunded for these
tickets and so it's not necessarily a
scam but they should have contacted seat
geek and taken the tickets off and so
he's like i don't know if yours is
season tickets or single the only way to
find out is to scan it
you're like oh my goodness and i'm like
oh man this could change like like i'm
thinking
i'm thinking
i'm on a dad level at this point right
so it's like the green rec for me
represents him being excited about this
school and the red i'm like this is
going to ruin us everything he's going
to have this
sour taste in his mouth about this
school and he's not going to want to go
and did
did the guy tell you that if it was read
that it was you didn't get your money
back or you did he said
well he didn't tell me that yet
okay well go ahead then he scanned them
and they scanned red
and i was like oh gosh man dang we
playing this whole day coming down here
to watch this game
and like lock is obviously really
disappointing shepard's just kind of
chilling
uh that at that point he said you need
to contact seat geek because um
in a person's name i'm not gonna say the
name the person's name is on the ticket
and so like the things that we were
saying about this person who had done
this to us was very we were it was a
running joke the rest of the week about
how we were going to hunt this person
down
obviously we didn't have to do that
because we contacted c geek and actually
well they're like investigating it but
i'm pretty they said that you will get
up to 120 percent of your money back
well you might make money off yeah this
might be a new way to like make some
side money okay
not go to basketball
uh but i think we had to pivot it
happened with multiple people i think
we'll get our money back but it was
interesting because like lock was
definitely disappointed and then
but he's kind of
been very interested in this place
and it kind of was a threw a little bit
of cold water on him but then
i felt like it was it kind of centered
him a little bit
and he's still very into the possibility
of going but he was very excited about
the next place and he's very excited
about some places that we're going to
see he's going to hear back from soon
the places we might see in the in the
spring
and so i think it actually was a
blessing in disguise because if we had
gotten the green check it might it might
falsely
weigh the uh the scales tip scales um
but one of the things that i found
myself think thinking i wonder if this
might really just want to go to gonzaga
is really good you know if this is the
case with you
not just
i mean even just like helping lily move
into college like being on a college
campus
oh we jesse and i were trying to explain
to the kids
how
different our college experience was
there's all these like groups of people
doing things and like clubs and
activities there's so much to do in
college and i was like i don't think you
guys understood
we did two things
the first thing we did is we went to
class
and the second thing we did is
everything with campus crusade yeah we
did not do anything else our entire
social life every single
activity that we had
was
just it was our campus ministry that we
were involved with which
you know
again i don't have any regrets about
where there were so it was like from a
social standpoint oh it you know we made
a lot of great connections and we had a
lot of good relationships i don't i
don't
i don't regret any of that but it was
just so interesting how going in with
such a singular
world view that had already
you know solidified and really hadn't
solidified but it felt like it has
solidified yeah it just i was like man
that's one thing that i i see when i'm
on a college campus just like there's so
much to like learn and experience and do
that i just completely sealed myself off
from because of my worldview at the time
well i mean
lily's
experience so far has been it's you know
the opportunities have been pretty
limited the majority of her classes
she's on a quarter schedule so it's like
and she's
like three out of her four classes
were
online even though she was like taking
them from her bed from her desk in her
dorm room
and um
only one was in person
and and now
this year
things have been delayed getting going
again everything's been
online
at least temporarily you know as they're
monitoring things but she's
i mean she is on campus
and so
i mean it was like
man if
if classes continue to only be virtual
it's like should we rethink this whole
thing
you know it's like you start to think
those things because her experience is
because it's not any cheaper she's got
it no she's got her roommates she's met
a few people she's doing you know she's
she got involved she joined a garage
band
which i was real you know i'm like this
is cool this is another this isn't
this is another experience that you if
you haven't had
uh
that was so formative for us more in
high school than college for us but
i'd still get this sense that like you
know clubs really aren't kicking into
gear and
the amount of camp the campus life is
still very stifled
by
kovitt so
it's i'm frustrated on her behalf
that you know her first year is kind of
a hat it's kind of a half college
experience
but at this point we're like it's it's
still going good and it's definitely
better than
nothing
and
uh well that was trying to make the most
of it and we're just trying to encourage
her it's harder to say well go out and
get involved in this group or
you know expand your potential
your pool of friends
you know so it's not just whoever you're
assigned with is who you're with
but you know have some autonomy and
being able to like meet people get
involved in different circles so that
you can start making some decisions
about the type of people you want to
associate yourself with i think as a
parent
i get concerned when it's like
this is who you're assigned to live with
and your
you're kind of limited beyond that you
know
so
that's an
i'm excited about the band thing just
because
of what i said that was formative for us
but also just that it represents a
an overlapping but different friend
group
you know and you so you think about a
lot going off next year hopefully things
will
have gotten
you know gotten to a point where it can
be
a dynamic experience and it will be for
lily and then
for
for lincoln too well because when you
walk around a college campus and you see
the buildings and you see the residence
halls and you see the gathering areas
that actually hit me it was like man
this place is designed to be at
it's not designed to be
to be
at home in in you taking online classes
yeah
you know that's the wonderful thing
about a classic university experience
which let me just say has become
first of all has always been and is
becoming more and more a privilege
right but also i think it's becoming
less and less of a necessity
because for a lot of people
if you don't have
a way if you're not getting a
scholarship if you're not finding a way
to pay for it whether it's your family
or your scholarship or you're working
through college or whatever
like for most people
it's going to be taking on a bunch of
debt
and not necessarily having a job to pay
that debt down
so i do think that i if i also had this
feeling as i walked around and looked at
all these buildings that kids were just
beginning to enjoy but for the past two
years they've just kind of been sitting
there in a lot of ways
this college campus that's not being
taken advantage of it's being paid for
by a bunch of kids who are at home on
their laptops
but i was just thinking about like yeah
this is not
you know
this isn't for everybody and it's gonna
become it has a you sort of feel like
you're walking through something that's
just not a lasting way of doing higher
education
it's like take advantage of it while you
can kind of kind of feel because there's
i mean you have to think that
all these people taking online classes
has well first of all i think we can all
agree they're not as good as in person
classes and we don't want that to be the
new normal
but no good god i look over lily's
shoulder when she you know she didn't go
back as early as we planned because she
was like i'll just stay another week
because i'm going to take all my classes
online
see my high school friends that i've
still been hanging out with but have
some quality time with him before i go
back i'm looking over her shoulder at
like a lecture she was like eating
breakfast and like walking around the
house with it on her phone and
with her i was like take your
take your earbuds out let me listen to
this
and it was just some
some guy just
i mean
just drawing on and on and on about
just like speaking extemporaneously and
like trying to find his words he might
be doing that in class as well but yeah
but when you're there in the room and
there's other people and you're like
it's not as hard it can't i mean that
it's just so hard when it's just a
screen
well and getting out of your i think for
me part of it is
getting out of your route getting out of
your house and literally having to like
put a backpack on and walk to a place
and go into an institution of higher
learning with other people who are there
for the same purpose yeah there's a lot
of psychology
in that
that is helpful to most people
but but there's no doubt that this that
covet has accelerated the the shift
right because people are like whoa whoa
i'm paying
you know in some cases like 50 000 a
year
for like a private school
for for like
university of phoenix you know i'm
saying like
nothing against people who have online
degrees i'm just saying that
the difference in value between the
value proposition between these two
things over the past couple of years has
really really gone down
the difference in the value proposition
because you're not really i mean you're
not getting that much different than
what you would have gotten from
something online
but you're still paying so much for it
and in the meantime
the prices just continue to go up i mean
listen as as a person who's potentially
considering a run for governor
i gotta say this is a real problem this
is a real problem
we gotta figure this out well
i mean i wanted to ask at this point do
you have a sense of like
and this is kind of switching gears but
still within parenting
of
the stakes associated with this decision
because you can really i mean i think
for me i could really overthink it and
kind of wig out over it's like
you know if lot gets accepted at
multiple places he's making this
decision that then he's keenly aware
because he's
future minded
that it's like this leads to this leads
to this leads to this and there's a fork
in the road that that leads to that at
least that leads to that
and never the two shall meet it's like
you can know maybe you can overthink it
over
dramatize it
and the butterfly effect of it so to
speak but it's
you can really get in your head about it
because it's a huge milestone decision
and you're not quite there yet so maybe
it's not but but i know i think about
this there's a there's a few things that
are helpful in this particular regard
the first thing is
locks nature right so even if i had a
specific plan that i thought was best
for him i am incapable and believe that
anyone would be incapable of prescribing
that to him in a way that would be
effective
so
it would be kind of a hopeless
would be a lost cause to try to tell him
where he needs to go or tell him what's
best for him he is going to learn things
his own way i can i can provide advice
and i can provide information but is he
so
on his own
that
i have such a little influence in that
in that area that it feels like there's
less pressure the second thing is just a
general
i think it's very healthy the thing that
we've been talking about a lot in in who
jesse and i have been talking a lot
about is loving detachment
you know the principle of
support loving detachment is not
a verb and a noun it's a it's a term
yeah you don't enjoy being detached it's
it's practicing something called loving
it is detachment that is loving okay
what is that so uh
it is
i mean first of all your motive is you
obviously you love your kid and you are
invested in their future you're helping
them you're providing them with
resources you're doing all the stuff
that you have control over right but
what you do not have control over is the
decisions that they make you have
control over how they're supported
and you can have control over like
whether or not you take them to the
school to look at it right
but you don't have control over what
they choose and if you think you have
control over that you are sorely
mistaken and if you exert control over
it then that it will backfire that that
could be trouble and so this isn't just
to do with college this is a principle
that we have sort of been
really talking about a lot over the past
couple years
jesse and i've been talking about
just raising kids in general but
especially raising teenagers as you
begin to get to that threshold where
they're beginning to become their own
people and they are making their own
decisions about things and if you know
kids are different like i've
said multiple times
locke is on the high end of the spectrum
when it comes to autonomy and
self-motivation and just like his will
right and so
you have to this is the only approach
that you you cannot dominate him right
he's an enneagram eight and their
greatest fear
is being dominated that is the fear of
the eight right and so that's why
sometimes you can be like let's listen
to this book on paper let's try this or
let's do that let's go eat at this place
and he's like no let's not do that it's
in his nature to be like oh i'm not
about to be dominated by you am i right
okay and so it leads to people who tend
to be doers and
self-motivated people who go out and
make [ __ ] happen for themselves a lot
um
but it also leads to people who are
going to learn things their way and
maybe learn things the hard way
sometimes
so yeah it it's this is not this is not
easy and yeah and loving detachment so
you you have to you got to still bring
the love to the situation but yeah i so
to answer your question specifically
100
i am aware of this dynamic which is
the slightest little thing
the the butterfly flapping his wings
could have could have this catastrophic
or very monumental effect right and so
where he decides to go to school is
going to determine his life path
but
this is the third piece of the puzzle
for locke is that
he i mean he's probably gonna transfer
no matter where he goes
you know what i'm saying like he he's so
like he's always looking to mix it up
and try something new
that
i just don't even have them like he's i
mean maybe he'll stay at the same place
but he's gonna want to be something else
he's going to do something else he's
going to try something else he's going
to go to a different place and so to me
this is just like this is the nature of
him and he's going to do a bunch of
different things
and i want to help him make the best
decision possible but
ah he's probably going to change his
mind anyway
it's kind of it's akin to
our my experience with lily in that like
i really built up
the the rite of passage of her leaving i
mean you can go back and listen to those
episodes and like there's a couple like
in that when i was in that zone of
sending her off
and like dealing with it
i
i said that i dramatized it to fully
embrace the experience but it was
you know it was okay she's going off
and she's our relationship is different
and she's gonna come home a different
person
and she's not
she doesn't live with us anymore and lo
and behold you know after
last thanksgiving and christmas and then
like
the the the pandemic situation and
virtual learning it's like
she's still home way too much
and i'm like man it's like we got over
that really quick
you know it's like get on back to
college you know kind of
kind of a message like
yeah so it's it as big of a decision
that it as it is
uh
you know there's there's always
room to pivot and you're kind of always
looking for
okay
do i need to is there a change on the
horizon or not
yeah and
you know this takes a little pressure
off this is really something that
i
it wasn't even on my radar
when my kids were little
and i don't necessarily think he would
be on my radar if i wasn't in therapy i
mean there's other ways to get to this
but
um
just beginning to recognize
how much of what we want for our kids is
just about us
you know
and like we say that it's a we say that
it's a it's for their best interest and
i and i do believe that a big part of it
is i think we we all love our children
genuinely
but they're
but mixed into that love is a lot of
how this reflects on you you know
and so like what my kid ends up doing
and who they end up being and like are
they going to be like something i can be
proud of or they're going to be someone
that i'm going to be ashamed of
and it that's all about you am i going
to be proud of them am i going to be
ashamed of them am i going to need to
help them among it you know what i'm
saying like
and
there's a lot of that that i have to
that's difficult it's a very difficult
thing for me to just again that's part
of the detachment is that is detaching
my
self-worth
to with my kids self-worth or my or my
self-worth with my kids
you know
accomplishments reputation whatever
whatever it is right
and kids can feel that too i mean this
is the story as old as time that kids
feel the expectations of their parents
right
but
that's been a helpful thing
to
just be like
man okay what ends up
happening with our kids whether they end
up the career they end up choosing
the the person they end up
you know getting into a relationship
with whether they're not they get
married or not like all these things and
whether we like it or not we've got sort
of these ingrained scripts in our minds
just given where we're from and even
though we've kind of
laid aside a very traditional way of
thinking about things
when you look at the lives that we've
lived well they're still pretty
traditional right like we got married
we're still married
we there's there's a there and so there
you you're sort of these built-in
expectations like that i want that exact
same thing for my kid whether you say it
out loud
and if my kid doesn't get that then
something's wrong with them right that's
the
that's a narrative that can kind of be
going in in your head
yeah um i think for me it's an impulse
like to believe the illusion that i can
control
their happiness that i do know what's
best
i think when you taking taking this big
decision of like going off to college or
any any
any big decision or just any life
decision it's like
there's this illusion that you can make
the right choice
you know a lot of times it's
that is just an illusion
it's more of like or illusion that you
can have all the information that like
makes it a mathematical there's a
mathematical solution
like i i tend to believe that thing
and believe that in the back of my mind
about a lot of things and when it comes
to parenting it's like i can control
their
i know what's best for their happiness
but then realizing
there's so you know we're making these
decisions based on limited information
and
so just saying you know what i'm going
to do the best i can in my role
but it
and even if i think something's the best
thing to do
but i'm relinquishing that decision to
them even if they do something different
it's it's saying okay
i'm going to lovingly detach
in in a way that lets them go for it
yeah obviously within within a certain
reason well and it's like i tell lincoln
it's like okay lincoln
uh
your mom and i have decided this is both
of us talking to him that you have to
you gotta you gotta get a job
you gotta get a job for a number of
reasons but it's
and you got x a number of weeks to
really start to
get some answers on this front generate
some leads
like you can you can find you can try to
find the best place that you want to
work
but the fact that you have to get a job
is something that we're saying for you
you need to do so we're looking for a
pool guy a pool guy
yeah i don't think that's steady enough
work for him
no but i mean but what if it's just like
full-time full-time constantly he's like
the lifeguard and 40 hours a week in my
pool
i mean keeps it [ __ ] and span
i pay minimum wage
i give him 30 hours a week that's what i
can't do more than that
no i don't i don't think i want to have
this this type of i don't want to bring
nepotism into this
so
i mean
what else do you have to say about the
subject or do you want to switch to the
san francisco of it all because you also
tease that yeah i do i want to say i do
want to get to that
uh i had one as you were as you were
saying that about lincoln um
uh i was thinking something it'll come
to me in a second but then when i was
like he should be my pool boy i really
you got to go for that
i kind of i kind of lost it all well i
was saying hey you got to get a job okay
you decide what kind of job you want to
get as long as you get one within
certain parameters
yeah i'm letting you make that level of
this well and i don't th this is what i
want to say it's i i don't want to paint
the picture that parenting is this like
hands-off
wish them well type approach i mean i
think but when they're 17 and about 10
and 18 in a month it kind of is
um
but
i think that it's recognizing
what you actually what you actually have
the power to do right
and again it's it's it's that i have the
power to create an environment
that is catered towards their happiness
success flourishing but i don't have the
power to guarantee it no i don't think
power to guarantee anything
and that's a very difficult thing and
you know one of the things that i found
with locke being someone who just
doesn't want to be told what to do
is that
maintaining the relationship being the
goal through the ups and downs and the
craziness that was coveted and the
restrictions and our kids lives being
turned upside down
making the goal maintaining the
relationship so that we're still
communicating we're still talking about
things so that then
it might not be like i have to resist
when he brings something up potential
circumstance or something he's going
through or something he knows
uh
that could happen
getting in there and trying to dab the
situation to death and like give my
perspective and try to control the
outcome
but if i can just have a conversation
about something and not come in real
hard with the moral of the story what i
found is that he is actually interested
he's interested in my perspective now
that my perspective is not gospel is not
always going to be right
but you know
jesse and i are his closest
advisors
and we're doing our best and i think we
give some pretty good advice some pretty
good advice but
yeah it's just that balance
um and then i mean like i said once
they're once they're gone it's a it's a
you're even less there's even less of an
influence they'll be back yeah
it'll still be more than you think is
what i'm telling you from the other side
of that but you have i'm saying you have
less of an influence
yeah but not every with every year that
passes but it wasn't nearly as drastic
as i thought at least for
for for us with lily um
so
san francisco i love san francisco i
didn't realize how much i did love it
it's been a while since i've been there
and
we realized that we had never been there
as a family and it was you know this was
mlk weekend that we thought we traveled
um and it was kind of like like saying
hey like there's some schools out there
i'm interested in so let's let's make
this happen
so we made it was a family trip of
course and i was just reminded how
awesome san francisco is
what resonates most with you because i
think you might just be city deprived
well i i love cities
and i'm a big fan of new york city
uh now i love la and no plans to move
right but the thing about la is this
giant super spread out city where you
just go through
miles and miles and it's just like i
don't even know what this is this is
kind of like urban sprawl from like the
40s you know what i mean
and there's no discernible like change
in landscape in many places and it's
like it just okay there's a there's a
convenience store there's a place to get
my car repaired and there's a place to
get hamburgers repeat repeat repeat
repeat repeat repeat repeat repeat yeah
for miles right you should you should be
governor
tourism
and so
but you if you once you live in los
angeles
gotta start with mayor once you live in
los angeles you start figuring out where
the where the the cool stuff is and
there's you know
it's a never-ending party if you want it
to be
but there are places like new york where
i call them the nooks and crannies where
you literally can be on the island of
manhattan and walk in any direction and
there's going to be people eating
shopping having a good time talking and
it's never going to stop and you're
never going to go through any like weird
urban sprawl where you're just like i
don't know what's happening here it's
just like it's just more
city and a lot of people turn off by
that but i just like that so what if
that applies to san francisco san
francisco plus hills though yeah exactly
san francisco is the nooks and crannies
of new york city
without
with with the exception of downtown
without all the high rise of san francis
of of new york so it's more like
two-story town homes
with restaurants and then like
restaurants and cool shopping kind of
mixed in and it's all
similar to new york in that it's isi
this is my theory
isolated to
a body of land that's surrounded by
water so you know that basically the
peninsula comes up in the bay and that's
where like downtown san francisco is on
any time you start putting water in a
situation and surrounding things with
water people don't like to
it creates this barrier but then with
the undulations in the land that you get
in san francisco it's like everywhere
you turn you're getting these
spectacular views of the whole thing and
you'd be like we were just right there
now we're right here and then because
you're in north california northern
california norcal
you've gotten out of the desert and so
the green is everywhere right that's the
thing that kids were saying is like it's
so green there's so many trees
and you'll be like chilling out in a in
an area town
and then like we were we went to uh
haight ashbury which is you know like
it's basically like the greenwich
village of san francisco so like the
history of like music and
drug culture in this yeah it's kind of
like hippie hippie place now
a little bit touristy
but we kind of were walking next to this
little park it was like buena vista park
and we're like let's just walk through
this park to get to the other side and
we start walking in there and then we're
like man this is like a big place and
it's like a big hill and all and all of
a sudden we're at the top of this like
in the trees you could feel like you've
completely stepped into nature and
you're literally just like really 200
feet from more just san francisco but
you get you've got the food you've got
the art you've got
the culture that you get in a big city
but you've got this and then you're
really close to
incredible nature right outside of the
town as well
then they basically have their own
central park
thanks jennifer for recommending i don't
know how i'd miss this but like i've
only been in san francisco a couple
times but and kind of in and out but the
golden gate
park
which really isn't close to the golden
gate bridge you can kind of see it from
there but it's sort of like its own
version of central park with museums and
a japanese tea garden and a baton
botanical garden which i love platonic i
love botanical gardens
i
when i die
i want at least a portion of my ashes to
be sprinkled in a botanical garden and i
don't mean just like the woods i mean a
place where they're like
somebody's taking care of the plants
just a random one i mean i have to pick
one okay i have to pick one i need to
put that in my will i wanted to ask you
i mean to kind of end on a on a happy
note yeah i wanted to ask about the
picture so you can
i mean
basically can i describe it
you want to describe it you can describe
it so uh this was there's a couple of
pictures though this was there was two
pictures you and jesse and locke
standing with the backdrop of the golden
gate bridge
and but it you had split screened it
where you were taking a picture with
lock as like
a a one-year-old and now
as a less than one almost 18 year old so
18-year difference you you match the
same photo
we're trying to match it as well you did
a damn good job that's why my question
was like did shepard take this photo and
i i didn't you know i wanted to talk
about it because it's that's an it was
an amazing
and there's so much i love i'm glad i'm
glad that you thought so
first of all i don't want to get into
the technicality but first first i just
want to say
it that is a super sweet photo that
you know you got this little baby lock
and you're visiting san francisco and
then
you never could have known that like
almost 18 years later you would you'd be
visiting colleges and he would be huge
yeah you huge that's what happens to
them they get you you mean
huge well and okay it's beautiful so we
knew beautiful we did all you know we
did a bunch of cool stuff but that day
you know we had like uh
hung out at the fisherman's wharf and
like gotten something to eat touristy
sites and uh and again lovely i love it
it's great some people have offices out
there on those piers
maybe we could get one um
but the uh
i was like let's drive to the golden
gate bridge and if i was like i seem to
remember that you can kind of park and
like walk on it
you know yeah you can and so
uh we get down there
and we park
and we're like walking like right around
it's almost sunset that was kind of the
plan to get down there when the sun's
going down
and
first of all do you know people surf at
the golden gate bridge lock had said
something about behind boats or
something no there's waves coming in
there somehow there's waves that work
their way around like the point break
that's on the that's under the bottom of
the
south side
or the west yeah the south side of the
golden gate bridge and there's like
three or four guys out there surfing in
very cold water i'm sure oh yeah i mean
not only is it just northern california
three or four january okay so it's not a
hot spot no but like they were like
getting legit waves the waves were big
but
uh
we had not planned on doing that photo
okay we'd forgotten that it existed but
we get out and we're walking around
and i'm like
hold on
we took pictures here when we were on
summer project so the so the
the old pictures
would have been from
2004 because lot was born in 2004 and
this was he was born in february uh
2004. this was like
june
uh or july
of 2004. so he's just a few months old
he was in like a bjorn carrier type
thing and we were on project uh at santa
cruz so with campus crusade basically
the way campus crusade works is if
you're a student or staff
every summer
you go on these summer projects where
you essentially go to a city like link
went to santa cruz as a student christy
went to santa cruz as a student yeah and
then we that's where we went as staff
and you're basically just like you get
jobs at the local community but you're
kind of there as a group of christian
kids here the students get jobs and the
staff come and put on the
the project so it's like a it's kind of
summer campus but this but for college
students who get jobs but you're kind of
there to get jobs to learn how to
evangelize and witness to people you
know it's like getting get a job and
tell people about jesus
but when we went back as staff we were
helping train them and facilitate the
whole program and yeah me christy
and lily were there and then and you
jesse and lock were there we didn't go
to san francisco with you on that
particular day trip though i don't think
yeah i guess you didn't because i don't
have any pictures with y'all so you
remembered taking a picture i was like
golden gate bridge i was like we were
here and jesse was like oh yeah yeah
yeah there's a picture of me and lock
and lock was in a bjorn
and so
going in to the situation with that
level of planning is like okay this is
because then i'm like well we totally
got to recreate this picture and then
she gets to she gets to the pictures on
her phone
and
which i don't even know how she's got
pictures from 2004 on her phone somehow
like i think you moved them over to uh
yeah i moved all my stuff to google
photos you moved your stuff to like
apple photos yeah and now you have it
all on your phone which i do too which
is awesome yeah but hers are digital
hers or she's i don't know hers are
organized mine just have like before a
certain date they're just all in there
but like somehow i dated these right
right on her phone i don't know so
so there we are then there's a picture
of um i mean i'll bring out the pictures
so you can see them because we'll okay
so the first picture
is the picture of me and jesse and locke
in the bjorn and you can see the golden
gate bridge behind us and also like the
little there's like a little parking
area that's where those guys were
surfing down there with and so we could
be like okay i think we know where this
is i actually don't think that we found
exactly the same place or else they had
built
a new
thing here that's in the way i couldn't
really tell
but so once we realized that this is
what we wanted to do
i was like okay our family is everyone
is so opinionated and strong-willed that
getting anybody to like participate and
take a group photo is is just
immediately brings tension into a fan
and then you've got like a match up one
from
like 17 years old again you've got the
17 year old and the 13 year old and
they're like you know they love each
other and they get along but then it'll
suddenly turn into 17 year olds and 13
year olds like fighting and so now we've
got to get shepherd to take this photo
yes i'm like shepherd's got to take it i
was amazed at how much of a match there
was because i knew behind the scenes
there had to have been anguish well yeah
it was not pleasant so
so the first thing that happened was is
i kind of get up there i'm like okay
this is where we need to be guys this is
where we need to stand and i'm like
shepherd this is how you need to frame
it
then he's got like he's looking at the
old picture on jesse's phone then he's
got my phone and he's taking the picture
yeah and like he he's not saying the one
thing is he wasn't saying when he was
taking the picture
say when you're taking the picture i'm
squatting
and
then i looked at the pictures the first
set that he took and i was like oh the
angle's not right like this isn't
actually you don't need to be there you
need to be here and i was like actually
shepard let's do this
lock and mom you get in this situation
this is this you're going to take the
picture and then shepard you get in
where i'm gonna be
and then we'll switch places uh-huh do
you have that picture uh i don't think i
took the picture oh you didn't even take
it i don't think but you but you were
like i'm gonna stand right here and hold
the phone here so now you walk back over
here stand where i'm standing hold the
phone where i'm holding it which is what
i would have done yeah and but then if
you look then that makes everybody the
thing that i'm a little bit disappointed
in
is like if you look at the previous
picture so locks in the bjorn and like
my hand is on his
chest and link and uh link
jesse's hand is on his crotch right
because because he's like in a bjorn and
she's kind of holding him and then he
he's got his eyes closed like if you get
you're going to put your hand on
ten-year-old cry if we had done the
complete like i didn't even put my hand
on him and he's not like you know it's
sort of just like the same thing
unwieldy he's not a baby the same three
people right so and then if you were in
the same place that was amazing well
here's what i told jesse and the kids i
was like guys this is good enough for
family it's not good enough for the
internet that's what i that's what i
actually said yeah of course now it's
good enough for the internet because
you're seeing it's cool it's cool um but
then a much better camera but the second
thing yeah because the first one was
probably just a film camera the second
picture was while we were walking so
it's really easy you can just walk on
the golden gate bridge
um
and
this one was much easier to sort of get
the angle and it was just two people it
was locked
look at that
me taking the picture so like dr evil uh
let's see
so again this was not easy and there was
some consternation from locke in this
one because i was like dude no you got
to look mean you got to look madder and
like this is as mad as he was willing to
that's pretty good to go but no we
should have shaved his head for it so
jesse posted this one on
uh
her twitter it's got like i don't know
it's got like 12 000 likes when i'm
recording this i'm sure he's got more
than that now but
um people were really into this
and commented on
the fact that jessie has not aged which
she really hasn't
locked has look at him boy yeah he's
changed quite a bit he's still a little
got a lot of angst
well it seems like you made him do that
but you know we had a you know what it
was worth it we had a really good moment
on the golden gate bridge
like i said you know
there was a moment when we were getting
ready to when we had just gotten into
the car to leave where shepard was like
dad
couldn't you just let lot drive in his
own car
and follow us up to san francisco
and i was like you guys are so spoiled
man like the fact that you would even
ask that you know what my dad would have
said if i had asked if one of us could
have driven separately i was like i'm
not even gonna answer that question
but
they weren't getting along right and
this is probably typical of a lot of
families you're getting ready to travel
it's like that just seems that's when
everything goes wrong that's when
everybody starts getting mad everybody's
fuses get super short and then you all
just get into the car together and go
right
and we did everybody did calm down but
there were some times where
there was
some
lock and shepard will kind of fight each
other a little bit like playfully and
sometimes it'll get it'll get a little
bit out of hand you know two boys
fighting and then all of a sudden
somebody's upset
and i kind of have to break it up
and of course
everyone has their own
stuff that they get upset about
but when we're walking on the golden
gate bridge
i don't remember exactly what lock said
but he essentially says something like
listen
we're all going to die one day
he was like and we were also kind of
honestly we were thinking about people
jumping jumping off the bridge because
it's like that was like 1700 people a
year or something or 1700 people
i can't remember it's a lot of people in
fact they're installing a net right now
and the in the supports
are out there ready to receive the net
so people won't jump off the bridge but
once you get to the middle of the bridge
there's nothing to keep you from jumping
off like there's no more
fence and stuff they have fence up so
that you can't get on the giant circular
wire that goes to the top because they
don't want you like daredevils
but in the middle
they're like if people are going to do
this they're going to do this until now
that they're installing the net so it
was on the brain so it gives you this
sense of
your own mortality
and he was just like listen we're all
going to die one day and i love you guys
and
i'm sorry for when i'm a jerk
and it was like this is beautiful and
we're all like we're sorry too like
we're all jerks sometimes
and just and i i think he ended up
saying something like and i like you
know
where i go to school doesn't even really
matter huh
and i was i was kind of like well it
kind of does but no matter but i didn't
say anything at the time we just had a
we had like a beautiful group hug that's
great you know what i would have said at
that moment i would have said
you know what this is beautiful let's
get a picture
and then i would have thrown it back
into chaos yeah we didn't get a picture
you just got a group hug on the golden
gate bridge we did we got a group hug on
the golden gate bridge
wow we also had a really interesting
thing happen where
right before as we were taking our we
were trying to get our first picture
with the three of us
some dude came up and it was like can i
can i help you guys and i was like ah
it's cool we're just trying to we were
like almost there i was like we're just
trying to recreate this photo
he was like cool it was with a group of
like five or six
young adults
you know
20 year olds whatever they were
and uh
and then they kind of like stand off to
the side and then when we finish
he's like hey can i get you to take a
picture of of us
i was like sure
and so they gave me their uh
polaroid camera that they were using oh
okay
and they all pose and i'm like okay and
then the guy's like okay on three
good mythical morning
and i kind of suspected that that was
what was happening but i didn't want to
be the guy that's just like you got
no so
shout out to the mythical beast that we
actually you know what turns out there's
a lot of mythical beasts on the golden
gate bridge
just hang out there pass like five of
them boost your ego um
so i hope the picture turned out good we
took two of them because jesse took a
picture of me taking a picture of them
and then i snapped it again and wasted a
little bit more of their film all right
well this brings me to my wreck i'm
pulling an audible here i had another
wreck i'll save it because my
recommendation is to take some photos
that then
18 years later you can
recreate or if it's later recreate them
and if you've if you've done this i want
to see you know a number of people do
this i saw a few of them like back
around the holidays people doing like
recreating family photos i love seeing
these
so hashtag ear biscuits if you've
already done this my recommendation is
the next time you're together
with with your loved ones
see about recreating a photo
if for no other reason just send it to
the linkster hashtag your business let
us know we talked about parenting a lot
today you know making big decisions and
not wigging out about it and i think
we're probably waiting perspective you
know the thing we talked about is we got
to go back 18 years or 17 years from now
you know and do and do this all again
when lock is what 35 is that how old
he'll be
no i can't do math 18 plus 18
18 plus 17 yeah he'll be 35
yeah and maybe he'll have a little child
and a bjorn who knows
we'll have to go back and do it of
course shepard won't be in any of the
photos because he wasn't in the first
one nope
not he wasn't there so he misses this
train
all right
our train will keep going we'll be
catching next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]